et je suis est très bouleversée depuis
le début de l'émission pardonnez moi je
vais essayer de finir mes phrases mais
l'exclusion de la famille je reconnais
que vous êtes de formation
le frère ou la soeur qui vous imitent
jusqu'à vous enviez jusqu'à vouloir
maintenant je me reconnecte maintenant
pour mathieu pardonnez moi tout ce que
vous dites on reconnaît que vous êtes en
forme au dessus
la seule différence est que justement
tout les expertises que lorsqu'on a été
battue ou bien on humilie à son tour ou
bien ceux banques ont toutes les
humiliations et ma question pour faire
simple c'est que j'ai l'impression vous
savez choisi d'humilier à votre tour
involontairement parce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure je n'arrivais plus à me
dire que je m'en prenais à tous ceux qui
étaient faibles et même les zips les
décès antisémite prouve que vous avez
été un enfant match et lorsqu'on a été
un enfant battu je peux vous dire qu'on
comprend tout ce que vous dites tout ce
que vous dites et qu'on ne laisse pas
une seconde
nous sommes seconde place au doute
pardonnez moi
[Applaudissements]
je me suis bien retenu fut nommé de paix
qui parle depuis la première fois qu'ils
parlent
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que et
honnêtement il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui comprennent pas mais je peux vous
dire quelle catégorie de personnes qui
ont été battus et qui vous comprennent
et vous savez en france il n'ya pas
d'étude sur les enfants battus devenu
adulte il y en a pas il y en a aux états
unis ou en grande bretagne y en a dans
les autres pays
mais aucune étude quasiment sur ce que
sont devenus des enfants adultes
lorsqu'ils sont devenus grands pourquoi
parce qu'en france est un vrai déni
il ya un vrai tabou et c'est ce tabou
dont vous souffrez aujourd'hui et je
encore encore une petite case à cocher
systématiquement la victime est
considéré comme coupable systématique
outre le fait que vous m'avez beaucoup
ce soir christine vous dit quelque chose
qui est très important cyril je viens
d'apercevoir d'une chose ce soir
depuis que mon livre est sorti on a
parlé de tout sauf de l'enfance battue
c'est le seul sujet dont on a jamais par
le prêt pas eu de débat société savoir
ce que j'ai fait qui dit quoi que
quelqu'un est sortie de l'hôpital
psychiatrique dit ceci cela la seule
chose qui n'a pas été traité et je viens
de le réaliser
vous rendez compte là à l'instant en
direct dans votre émission
il n'y a pas eu un débat à une seconde
consacrée à l'enfance battu et je crois
que la france est un des pays qui donc
ce domaine a malheureusement bat des
records absolument terrible et je vous
viennent vous venez de me faire réaliser
qu'on a parlé de tout depuis le mois
d'août sauf des enfants vous savez qu'à
l'heure où on parle en ce moment et des
enfants dans des placards les enfants
qui viennent de faire brûler outils
garrett et des enfants qui viennent de
se faire jeter dans l'ordre un bouillon
vous avez souvent y avait des émissions
dans les 80 sur les enfances battu des
caves une émission comme ça j'ai coupé
la radio je ne supporte pas ce sujet la
seule manière que j'ai réussi
pour dire la seule manière le seul livre
que j'ai réussi à lire sur l'enfance
battue c'est celui que j'ai écrit à
pouvoir lire sur l'enfance battu j'étais
obligé d'écrire le livre moi même est ce
que vous dites c'est qu'en fait tout ce
qui s'est passé le blocage des parents
le frère les avocats machin c'est pour
mettre une chape de plomb sur un tableau
qui l'enfance battu les femmes violées
je ne veux pas comparer on arrive à en
parler et heureusement je veux pas qu'on
parlait cause c'est ridicule mais il ya
un sujet dont on entend le harcèlement à
l'école je suis heureux qu'on en parle
en parler dans les maltraitances les
animaux on en parle beaucoup et c'est un
c'est très important parce que c'est ça
ressemble en fait et les enfants martyrs
jamais pas un mot pourquoi
c'est là je ne vais pas la réponse
pourquoi par semaine il ya deux à trois
enfants qui meurent sous les coups de
leurs parents en france voilà tu es
vraiment ce chiffre c'est c'est
incroyable merci en tout cas christine
ce témoignage merci ma chérie dans ses
poches
[Applaudissements]